are you getting into the holiday spirit
we're getting close Christmas coming up
get excited come on yes I am I am I
actually like the holidays and
Thanksgiving is my favorite because you
just get to eat and that type of thing
but uh I don't know I don't like that
Black Friday type of stuff that just
freaks me out makes me sad for Americans
watching them getting trampled you know
yeah you know I would you do that why
would you do that to yourself why would
you just admit that you can't afford it
at regular prices come back the next day
like a gentleman just walk in there pick
out what you want and if your kids get
less they get less that gives them Drive
you know rich gets rich kids just sit
around you know doing blow sitting in
Ferraris they don't do anything it's the
poor kids that they're they make stuff
happen so yeah yeah you know it trampled
grabbing your wig you know it's so sad
to do what get an above-ground pool for
$30 off there's nothing there is nothing
in Walmart worth getting trampled over
to me Russell processed meat close olive
if you gonna get trampled like make it
like a high-end store like you learned I
don't even I didn't know what it's
nothing worth getting trampled it just
makes me depressed yeah that you would
do that people sit out for like weeks
there's a week they don't even go to
Thanksgiving yeah like that on this
cellphone and their moms crying I just
so just figured water spending with us
and you're sitting out there in that
parking lot
failing those people breathing down the
back of your neck going like no one who
you're gonna elbow it's just the status
there are women that wait there wait
waited twenty two days at Best Buy they
waited twenty two days and what did they
get what do you think the guy I don't
know I think they got trampled yeah you
don't want to be at the front of the
line you want to be about forty deep and
I figure you pop out of the line and you
wait to that first wave or two falls
down and then you go over the top like
Walter Payton even then you gotta know
where to go in the store like where is
the thing that is on sale right where
are those mint Milano cookies you're
gonna make a beeline for on that
linoleum floor saddest thing it's one
year what people should do you know like
Richard Branson one of these hot air
baloon rich guys
just like floating over them right
before it and just start dropping
everything that they want and feeding
like no matter how many hot-air balloons
he had what bad idea you don't want with
billionaires in hot air balloons
dropping toasters on people
the idea a little parachute
all right gift certificates all right
you